I think they just like electing people  that they can control well that's 100  that absolutely like like that that guy  in Pennsylvania who was dead  people that were dead there were three  people there's three not in Pennsylvania  but there were not in Pennsylvania  there's one in Massachusetts one in  Pennsylvania and then one in somewhere  else in California  all Democrats yeah I said are we  supposed to have sympathy for the dead  God too well and what about the person  that was running against them like did  they not  I recently learned that you can't defame  dead people  so now we can say Democrats elected  fraudsters con artists and rapists oh  they're dead you can't defame them no I  don't want to disparage the people who  died I got no beef they say oh you have  no sympathy for a guy well I have no  sympathy for the person that's dead  either they're dead but I mean you still  elected them